NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lecture today is entitled
Implicit Differentiation.
And aside from other
considerations, this lecture
bares a very strong relationship
to many of the
comments that we've made about
single-valued functions and
one-to-one functions.
Let's get right into the topic
by talking about one
particular phase that somehow or
other we may have taken for
granted, but which really is a
lot more sophisticated than we
really imagine at
first glance.
Let's look, for example, at
an expression such as 'y'
equals 'f of x'.
A rather harmless expression,
we write it down quite
frequently, and we say
things like what?
Given that 'y' equals 'f
of x', find 'dy dx'.
And you see the point that we've
made here is we have
assumed that 'y' can
be solved for
explicitly in terms of 'x'.
In other words, in terms of
our function machine, we
visualize an 'f' machine.
'x' goes in as the input, 'y'
comes out as the output, and
everything is fine.
Now, the interesting point
is simply this.
Let's look at a slightly more
complicated algebraic equation.
For example, 'x to the eighth'
plus ''x to the sixth' 'y to
the fourth'' plus 'y to
the sixth' equals 3.
Now, in this particular example,
notice that 'x' and
'y' are not given at random.
For example, if I say let me
pick 'x' to be 2 and 'y' to be
2, and I put 2 in for 'x' and
2 in for 'y', just look at
what happens to the left-hand
side here.
It makes, in particular,
3 a pretty big number.
In other words, when 'x' is 2
and 'y' is 2, this equation--
and we'll talk about the meaning
of the equation more
in just a few minutes, but
this equation does not
balance, so to speak.
In other words, while we cannot
pick 'x' at random for
a given value of 'y', once 'x'
is given, notice that we wind
up with a sixth degree
polynomial equation in 'y',
which determines at most
six values of 'y'.
And if we're given a value of
'y' as a fixed number, we wind
up with an eighth degree
polynomial equation in 'x',
which means that what?
'x' is no longer
random either.
The point is it is very, very
difficult, if not impossible,
to try to solve this particular
equation for 'y'
explicitly in terms
of 'x' or for 'x'
explicitly in terms of 'y'.
And the question is
how do we tackle
something along these lines?
And we make a very
tacit assumption.
And by the way, you'll notice
that when you read this
section in the text, there are
several remarks saying that
many of the proofs are beyond
the scope of the textbook at
this particular point.
And they'll say we'll talk about
this later, and there
are references to more
advanced textbooks.
The point is that from a
more rigorous point of
view, this is true.
However, from a geometric
intuitive point of view, it's
quite easy to see what's really
going on here, as we
shall do with as the
lecture progresses.
But for the time being, let's
review what that tacit
assumption is.
Essentially what we say is let's
assume that 'y' is a
particular function of 'x'.
What particular function
of 'x' is it?
Well, it's that function of 'x'
such that when you replace
'y' by that function of 'x',
this becomes an identity.
And this is what I want
to talk about next.
You see, assume that 'y' is that
function of 'x' such that
when you replace 'y' in terms of
'x', 'x to the eighth' plus
''x to the sixth' 'y the
fourth'' plus 'y to the sixth'
is identically 3.
And notice the use of the three
lines here to indicate
the identity as opposed
to the two lines to
indicate the equality.
Now, obviously, there's a more
important difference than to
say that one is indicated
by three lines and
the other by two.
Let me take a few moments to
digress on a very important
topic, namely, the difference
between what we call an
equation, or perhaps more
appropriately, a conditional
equality, and that which we call
an absolute equality or
an identity.
For example, let's take a look
at an expression such as 'x
squared' equals 4.
You say, ah, these two things
are equals, and if I do the
same thing to equals,
I get equals.
So the fellow says I think I'll
differentiate both sides
of this equality.
If he differentiates 'x
squared', he gets '2x', and if
he differentiates
4, he gets 0.
Now notice that if you solve
the equation 'x squared'
equals 4, you get what?
'x' equals minus 2, or 2.
On the other hand, if you solve
the equation '2x' equals
0, you get x equals 0, and
there seems to be no
correlation between these two.
Now, you see the answer
to this thing is this.
'x squared' is not a synonym.
'x squared' is not another
way of saying 4.
To use the language of the new
mathematics, the solution set
for 'x squared' equals
4 is what?
The set of all 'x' such that
'x squared' equals 4.
That's another way
of saying what?
The set whose only two members
are 2 and negative 2.
In other words, we cannot
say that 'x squared' is
a synonym for 4.
All we can say is given the
condition if 'x' is either 2
or minus 2, then 'x
squared' equals 4.
Otherwise, this is
not the case.
For example, if you subtract 4
from 'x squared', you do not
get identically 0.
In other words, 'x squared'
minus 4 is not another
way of saying 0.
For example, if I put
'x' equals 3 in
here, this says what?
3 squared equals 4, which is
certainly a meaningful
statement, but nonetheless
a false statement.
You see, somehow or other, an
equation is something which
can be true for a certain values
of your variable but
false for others.
On the other hand, an identity,
as the name may
imply, is something that's
true for all
values of the variable.
For example, let's go back to
something we learned in
elementary school algebra: 'x
squared minus 1' equals 'x +
1' times 'x - 1'.
Notice I wrote this with
the three lines here.
It's my way of saying that for
any number 'x' whatsoever, 'x
squared - 1' always names
the same number as 'x +
1' times 'x - 1'.
In other words, the solution
set of this particular
equation includes all
real numbers.
Or another way of saying it is
that if you were to subtract
'x + 1' times 'x - 1' from the
'x squared minus 1', the
result would be 0 independently
of what the
value of 'x' was.
In more colloquial terms, what
we're saying is that 'x
squared minus 1' and 'x +
1' times 'x - 1' are two
different ways of saying
the same thing.
Now, the beauty of an
identity versus a
conditional equality is this.
That if two expressions are just
two different names for
the same thing, then whatever
is true for one expression
will be true for the other.
You see, in other words, if the
concept is the same but
only the names are different,
then certainly anything that
depends on the concept will not
depend on the particular
name that's involved.
Well, as a case in point, let's
suppose now I take 'x
squared minus 1' and
I differentiate it.
The result is '2x'.
On the other hand, if I take
'x + 1' times 'x - 1' and
differentiate it, I get what?
By use of the product rule, it's
the first factor times
the derivative of the second
plus the derivative of the
first factor times the second.
That's what? 'x + 1' plus
'x - 1', and that
comes out to be '2x'.
In other words, since these two
expressions were just two
different names for the same
thing, the derivative of one
of the expressions must equal
the derivative of the other
because it's still the same
function that you're
differentiating.
And this is what we mean when
we say let's assume that 'y'
is that function of 'x' that
makes the resulting equation
an identity.
Let's look at a particularly
simple illustration, and we'll
do this quite often
in this course.
Namely, whenever we want to
illustrate a new topic, we
will always, when possible, pick
an illustrative example
that could have been solved
by a previous method.
As a case in point, let's
look at the identity 'x'
times 'y' is 1.
See, in other words, 'y' is that
particular function of
'x', such that whenever you
replace 'y' by that function,
this becomes an identity.
Now, if that seems hard, notice
that we could turn this
into an explicit relationship
just by dividing both sides of
this equation, our
identity by 'x'.
Of course, that assumes
'x' is not equal to 0.
But if we do that, 'y'
becomes '1/x'.
Now notice that '1/x' has the
property that as long as 'x'
is not 0, if you multiply that
by 'x', you get identically 1.
'x' times '1/x' is 1.
Two different ways
of saying 1.
Now, how does the method
of implicit
differentiation proceed?
We say OK, since this is an
identity, if I differentiate
both sides with respect to 'x',
the derivative of the
left-hand side should equal
right-hand side.
Now, how do we differentiate
'x' times 'y'?
Observe that we're assuming that
'y' is a function of 'x'.
Therefore, 'x' times 'y'
is a product of two
functions of 'x'.
To differentiate a product,
we use the product rule.
Namely, we will take the first
factor times the derivative of
the second with respect
to 'x'.
That's 'dy dx', because 'y' is
the second factor, plus the
derivative of the first factor
with respect to 'x'.
Well, the derivative of 'x' with
respect to 'x' is 1 times
the second factor, which is 'y',
that's now the derivative
of the left-hand side.
That must equal identically
the derivative of the
right-hand side.
The right-hand side is 1.
The derivative of
a constant is 0.
So we wind up with the
relationship that 'x' times
'dy dx' plus 'y' must
be identically 0.
And now solving for 'dy dx' in
terms of 'x' and 'y', we find
that 'dy dx' is equal
to minus 'y/x'.
By the way, notice that by
picking a problem that could
be solved explicitly for 'y'
in terms of 'x', we have a
very simple check on this
particular problem.
Namely, we know that 'y', if
'x' is not 0, that y is
another name for '1/x'.
Therefore, minus 'y/x' is
another name for ''minus 1'
over 'x squared''.
But we already know that if 'y'
equals 'x to the minus 1'
by another method, we know that
'dy dx' is 'minus x to
the minus 2', which is also
''minus 1' over 'x squared''.
And so we see that the new
method does give us the same
answer as the old method.
By the way, let me
make a rather
important aside over here.
And that is when you look at
something like this, you might
say something like I wonder
what happens if I try to
compute 'dy dx', say, when 'x'
equals 2 and 'y' equals 3?
Now, you see if you mechanically
plug into
something like this,
you get what?
Minus 3/2, which is minus
three-halves.
The point that I want to bring
out, and we'll come to this at
the conclusion of today's
lecture also, is the concept
of related rates and
related variables.
Notice that whereas from this
equation it looks as if we can
let 'y' equal 3 and 'x' equal
2, notice that if we go back
to our basic definition, 'x'
and 'y' are related so that
they are not independent.
Notice that as soon as we say
let 'x' equal 2, we have what?
That '2y' is 1, and
'y' must be 1/2.
In other words, when you use
implicit differentiation,
never forget that whenever
you're going to compare 'x'
and 'y', you must go back to the
equation or the identity
which implicitly relates
'x' to 'y'.
Well, so far this may
look rather easy and
straightforward.
But the fact remains that there
are certain subtleties
here which we have
not hit yet.
So what I'd like to do now
is pick a second example,
slightly more complicated than
this one, which can still be
solved explicitly but which
leads to a wrinkle which we
may not have observed before.
With this in mind,
what I would like
to do is the following.
Let's consider the relation 'x
squared' plus 'y squared'
equals 25 and ask the question
how do you find 'dy dx' in
this particular case?
Again what we do is we assume,
and this is the big word here.
There are lots of things that
you can assume, but whether
they exist or not is
another question.
That's the part that the
textbook means is more
advanced and is hard
to justify.
But let's take a look here.
We'll assume that 'y' is a
particular function of 'x'
with the property that when 'y'
is that function of 'x',
'x squared' plus 'y squared'
is identically 25, OK?
And what that means is that
whatever 'x' and 'y' are,
they're related in such a way
that 'x squared' plus 'y
squared' is a synonym for 25.
If we now proceed by implicit
differentiation here, you see
the left-hand side is a function
which is the sum of
two functions of 'x'.
The derivative of a sum is the
sum of the derivatives.
The derivative of 'x squared'
with respect to 'x' is '2x'.
The derivative of 'y squared'
with respect
to 'x' is not '2y'.
The derivative of 'y squared'
with respect to 'y' is '2y'.
By the chain rule, the
derivative of 'y squared' with
respect to 'x' is what?
The derivative of 'y squared'
with respect to
'y' times 'dy dx'.
In other words, this
is simply what?
''2y' 'dy dx''.
So the derivative of the
left-hand side is '2x' plus
''2y' 'dy dx''.
The derivative of the
right-hand side, the
right-hand side being
a constant, is 0.
And if we now solve for 'dy dx'
in terms of 'x' and 'y',
we find that 'dy dx'
is 'minus x/y', OK?
This is all there is to this
thing mechanically.
By the way, of course, it
happens as you probably
remember, that 'x squared' plus
'y squared' equals 25 is
a circle centered at the origin
with radius equal to 5.
OK, so far so good.
We'll come back to this diagram
in a little while.
But the thing now is could we
have solved the same problem
by solving for 'y' explicitly
in terms of 'x'?
The answer in this case,
of course, is yes.
Namely, if 'x squared' plus 'y
squared' is 25, that says that
'y squared' is 25 minus 'x
squared', and therefore, the
desired function of 'x'.
'y' is what function of 'x'?
It's plus or minus the
square root of
'25 minus 'x squared''.
In other words, that's what?
It's the positive '25 minus 'x
squared'' to the 1/2 power.
That's one of the solutions.
And the other solution is the
negative '25 minus 'x
squared'' to the 1/2 power.
I simply use the exponent
notation because it's more
familiar to us in terms
of differentiation to
differentiate the exponent
rather than the radical sign.
But the idea is this: Notice
now that we begin to see a
multivalued function creeping
in over here.
In other words, we now find that
we want to solve for 'y'
explicitly in terms of 'x',
that we do get the problem
that y might be a multivalued
function of 'x'.
Well, we'll look at
that in a moment.
For the time being,
let's simply do a
double check over here.
Let's actually differentiate
this thing explicitly and see
what the derivative
turns out to be.
If we differentiate this,
we bring the 1/2 down.
We replace it to an
exponent one less.
And by the chain rule, we must
multiply by the derivative of
what's inside here, 25 minus x
squared with respect to 'x'.
That's 'minus 2x'.
Collecting terms and
simplifying, we get what?
'Minus x' over ''25 minus 'x
squared'' to the 1/2'.
And recalling that ''25 minus
'x squared'' to the 1/2' is
equal to the 'y' value in this
case, we get the derivative of
'y1' with respect to 'x' is
'minus x' over 'y1', just
calling the function this.
That at any rate shows what?
The negative x-coordinate over
the y-coordinate, and that
certainly checks with the result
that we had before.
In a similar way, if we now
differentiate 'y2' with
respect to 'x', bringing down
the exponent, multiplying by
the derivative of what's inside
with respect to 'x', we
wind up with the same expression
as we did before,
only now we remember that 'y2'
is defined to be negative ''25
minus 'x squared'' to the
1/2', so this is really
negative y2.
By the way, notice again that we
get the same answer here as
we did here.
I like to keep the minus sign
with the appropriate term.
In other words, notice it was
the fact that 'y2' was
multivalued that caused us
to have two different
possibilities here in
the first place.
Now, let's go back to our little
graph over here and
take a look to see just
what happened here.
Remember, all through this
course, we've said what?
Be aware of what happens
when 'y' equals 0.
Notice in terms of our picture
and our related rates here,
when 'y' is 0, 'x' is not
some arbitrary number.
When 'y' is 0, since 'x squared'
plus 'y squared'
equals 25 when 'y' is 0, 'x'
must either be 5 or minus 5.
So what's happening is the bad
point when 'y' is 0, or the
bad points, are right here.
And notice the rather
interesting thing here, and
this is what comes up more
analytically later.
The only time you're in trouble
when you assume that
'y' is a function of 'x'--
remember, function mean
single-valued--
is that if you happen to be in
the neighborhood of 5 comma 0
or minus 5 comma 0, notice
that for any neighborhood
surrounding this point,
there is no way--
if this point here is included,
there is no way of
breaking up this function
to be single valued.
In other words, if you must have
a small portion of the
curve that includes 5 comma
0 as an interior point, no
matter how you do it, the
resulting curve is going to be
multivalued, and then we're in
the same predicament again.
In other words, from a
theoretical point of view,
geometrically speaking, it's
very easy to assume that 'y'
is a function of 'x' that makes
our equation an identity.
But from a real point of view,
what may frequently happen is
that the only type of function
that would work is what we
call a multivalued function.
That's exactly what's
going on over here.
And that's why a textbook,
which is trying to be
rigorous, has to be very, very
careful in explaining what
happens in neighborhoods
of points like this.
But again, we'll talk about
that in more detail in a
little while.
I would like to make one
aside over here.
You may recall that we learned
in one of our previous
lectures that by inverse
functions, we can
differentiate things like 'x'
to the 1/2, 'x' to the 1/3.
This generalizes very nicely
and very simply in terms of
implicit differentiation.
Namely, suppose you have 'y'
equals 'x to the 'p/q'' power
where 'p' and 'q'
are integers.
In other words, your exponent
is now a fraction.
Raise both sides to the q-th
power, and you get 'y' to the
'q' equals 'x to the p'.
Now, we know how to
differentiate powers of 'x' or
'y' if the power happens
to be an integer.
So by implicit differentiation,
assuming that
this is now an identity, which
it is if 'y' equals 'x to the
'p/q'', if we differentiate
both sides with respect to
'x', the derivative of the
left-hand side is 'qy to the
'q - 1'' times the derivative
of 'y' with respect to 'x'.
That is, we're differentiating
with respect to 'x'.
And the derivative of the
right-hand side is
'px to the 'p - 1''.
And since this is an
identity, these two
expressions must be equal.
If we solve now for 'dy dx',
we obtain this expression,
replacing 'y' by 'x to the
'p/q'', and multiplying out
here, and remembering that when
you have an exponent in
the denominator, it can come
up into the numerator by
changing the sign.
A little bit of arithmetic shows
that 'dy dx' is ''p/q' x
to the ''p - 1' minus 'p'
plus 'p/q'' power.
The 'p' and the 'minus p' cancel
out, and we find what?
That 'dy dx' is 'p/q' times
'x to the ''p/q' - 1''.
Remembering that 'p/q' was
our fractional exponent,
we again see what?
That to differentiate 'x' to
a fractional exponent--
'p/q'--
you bring the exponent down and
replace the 2 by one less.
So that gives us an alternative
method for finding
the derivative of a fractional
exponent by namely using
implicit differentiation.
Now, the reason I put that aside
in is we could certainly
get along without it.
But I felt that before we go any
further, that I would like
at least to add it on the more
elementary levels to be sure
that we understand explicitly
what implicit
differentiation means.
With this in mind, let's now go
back to the problem that we
started off with in this
lecture, namely, the curve
whose equation is 'x to the
eighth' plus ''x to the sixth'
'y to the fourth'' plus 'y
the sixth' equals 3.
And we say what?
Let's find the equation of the
line tangent to this curve at
the point 1 comma 1.
By the way, I did something
that teachers are
allowed to do here.
I rigged the problem to come
out rather simply.
You see, what I did was by
picking 1 and 1 here,
it turns out what?
That if I made the right-hand
side just equal to the number
of terms here, I would get
this thing to check out.
But notice, by the way, if I had
just picked the point at
random to try to even check
where that point is on this
curve, or if it were on this
curve, to find out what its
coordinates are, this is a
rather difficult problem.
In other words, if I just pick
a random value of 'x', as I
said before, I get a sixth
degree polynomial equation to
solve, and if I pick a random
value of 'y', an eighth degree
polynomial equation to solve.
You know, it might be nice to
pretend that the 8 was a 2 or
something like this and solve
it as a quadratic equation.
But quite frankly, solving
polynomial equations, which
are higher than the degree two
is a very difficult task.
In fact, if the degree is
greater than four, it may even
be an impossible task.
I'm not going to go into
that now because
it's not that crucial.
What is crucial is to observe
that this particular problem
makes sense.
It's a meaningful problem.
It would be difficult, if not
impossible, to solve for 'y'
explicitly in terms
of 'x' here, OK?
Yet to solve this problem,
we can now use implicit
differentiation except for the
fact that we can no longer
check back by another method to
see if the answer is right.
That's why I wanted to pick a
few introductory examples that
we could check by other means.
Now that we have a feeling for
this, maybe we will trust the
technique in a case where we
have no recourse other than to
use the technique.
So what we do now is this: We
say OK, let's assume that 'y'
is that function of 'x', that
differentiable function of 'x'
that makes this particular
equation an identity.
And assuming now that this
is an identity, let me
differentiate both sides
with respect to 'x'.
See, this is a sum.
One of the terms in the sum
happens to be a product.
But by now, hopefully how we go
about something like this
will be old hat.
Namely, to differentiate the
left-hand side with respect to
'x', we get what?
'8x to the seventh' plus what?
The derivative of 'x to the
sixth', which is '6x to the
fifth', times the second
factor, which is 'y the
fourth', plus the first factor,
which is 'x to the
sixth', times the derivative
of 'y to the fourth' with
respect to 'x'--
that's ''4y cubed' 'dy dx''--
plus the derivative of 'y to
the sixth' with respect to
'x', which is ''6y to
the fifth' 'dy dx''.
That must be identically 0.
And if we now solve this for 'dy
dx', just by transposing,
we wind up again with a rather
messy expression, but which
does show what 'dy dx' looks
like in terms of 'x' and 'y'.
We were interested in knowing
what the slope was not only
for any old value of 'x' and
'y' but rather for what?
When 'x' is 1 and 'y' is 1.
And that works out very nicely
computationally.
It's just minus 14/10.
In other words, at the point
1 comma 1, the slope of the
curve is minus 7/5.
The curve passes through
the point (1, 1).
Hence, it's equation is 'y - 1'
over 'x - 1' equals minus
7/5, or more explicitly,
'7x + 5y' equals 12.
And the point that I wanted to
make here is notice that
nothing changed in principle
from our first few lectures.
Notice that to find the equation
of the line, we still
use the recipe that we have
to know a point on the
line and the slope.
The only thing that's changed
with today's lesson is that we
can now find the slope of a
curve at a particular point
that we could not find prior
to today's lesson.
All that has changed is that we
have one more technique for
finding the derivative of a
particular type of function.
I would like to analyze this
problem in more detail.
In particular, I would like to
see where the numerator of
this expression can
be 0 and where the
denominator can be 0.
Because you see in terms of
slopes, where the numerator is
0, it means the slope
will be 0.
That means we have a horizontal
tangent line.
Where the denominator is 0,
that means the slope is
infinite, OK?
And where the slope is infinite,
that means you have
a vertical line, and that means
you have a vertical
tangent, OK.
So let's take a look and
see what that means.
Keep this particular equation
in mind, because now you see
on the next board, all I want
to do is work with what this
thing means.
In other words, 'dy dx' will be
0 when my numerator is 0.
My numerator can be written
in this particular form.
And by the way, here's again
an interesting point.
When will this expression
be 0?
And the answer is when either
of these two factors is 0.
Well, the first factor
is 0 when 'x' is 0.
And the second factor is 0,
since these are even powers,
only when 'x' and
'y' are both 0.
Notice, however, that 'x' and
'y' cannot both be 0.
Recall that the equation
was what?
Whatever it was, notice that
(0, 0) is not a point which
satisfies the equation.
Remember, (0, 0) does not
satisfy 'x to the eighth' plus
''x to the sixth' 'y squared''
plus 'y to the
sixth' equals 3.
It's equal to 0, you see.
But at any rate, notice
that the slope is 0
only when 'x' is 0.
And because of the particular
equation, when 'x' is 0--
well, we'll go back to
that in a minute.
Let's just check to see
what's happening here.
The denominator will be 0.
In other words, when 'dx
dy' is 0-- '1 over
'dy dx'', you see--
only when this factor here is 0,
and that occurs again only
when 'y' is 0.
Now, the point to keep
in mind is this.
Remember, I put this down here
so we could refer to it, and I
forgot that I put it here, and
that's why I didn't see it
until just now.
All I'm saying here is that
notice that when 'x' is 0, 'y'
must be plus or minus
the sixth root of 3.
And when 'y' is 0, these two
terms drop out. 'x' must be
plus or minus the eighth
root of 3.
Coming over to a graph here
then, what we see is that the
curve crosses the x-axis
at this point
with a vertical tangent.
It crosses the y-axis
at this point with
a horizontal tangent.
Notice, by the way, that this
curve is also symmetric with
respect to both the x- and
the y-axes, because
if I replace 'x'--
well, it's not important, and
I don't want to obscure the
lecture by taking time
out for this now.
But the point is a quick check
shows that this curve is
symmetric with respect to both
the x- and the y-axes, that if
I could plot this curve just
in the first quadrant, the
mirror image with respect to the
y-axis would then show me
the second quadrant.
If I then took the mirror image
of this upper half with
respect to the x-axis, that
would give me the lower
portion of this curve.
The curve tends to look
something like this.
And by the way, all we've done,
if we look back over
here if you can see this OK, the
'7x + 5y' equals 12 simply
turned out to be what?
The equation of the line which
was tangent to this curve at
this particular point.
What I'd like to show you in
terms of one-to-oneness and
single-valuedness is this.
I told you I was interested in
what was happening at this
curve at the point 1 comma 1.
Suppose I had said instead find
the equation of the line
tangent to this curve at the
point whose x-coordinate is 1?
Well, you see, there are two
points on this curve whose
x-coordinate is 1.
You see, this is a double-valued
curve.
A given value of 'x' between
these two extremes yields the
two values of 'y'.
I would have had no way of
knowing which of the two
y-values I meant, you see?
And correspondingly, if somebody
had said find the
slope of the curve, of the
equation of a line tangent to
the curve, at the point whose
y-coordinate is 1, notice that
this is not 1 to 1.
In other words, if the
y-coordinate is 1, notice that
I cannot distinguish between
the point 1 comma 1 and the
point what?
Minus 1 comma 1.
You see, there's again our
problem with inverse functions
and things of this
particular type.
If we're told the neighborhood
of the point that we're
interested in, we're fine.
If all we're told are one of
the coordinates and have to
find the other, there is a
certain amount of ambiguity.
And keep in mind, by the way,
that I deliberately rigged
this problem to get something
I could graph at least.
In many cases, it's much more
difficult to even visualize
what the graph looks like,
much more complicated.
You see, computationally, this
can be come quite a mess.
The important point is that what
we were doing implicitly
here assumed on the explicit
fact I could take this curve
and break it down at the points
where I have vertical
tangents and look at this as
two separate curves: 'c1',
namely, the original curve, but
restricted to 'y' being
non-negative, and 'c2', the
original curve, but restricted
to 'y' being negative.
In other words, I can look at
'c1' as being this piece and
'c2' as being this piece.
And again, the point is what?
That whenever you're in the
neighborhood of these points,
you're in trouble.
Because notice that no matter
how small a neighborhood I
pick, if I can't tell one of
these branches from the other,
no matter how I do this, I'm
going to be caught on a
multivalued part of the
curve over here.
Well, at any rate, I think this
begins to show us what
implicit differentiation means,
why we have to be
careful of points at which
vertical tangent occur, but I
would like before closing this
lecture to generalize the
concept of related rates and
make this a little bit more
applicable from a physical
point of view.
And that is when we say in
something like this that let's
assume that 'y' is a
differentiable function of
'x', there is no reason to
have to assume that the
variable you want to relate
things to is 'x' itself.
For example, let me do something
which uses the same
kind of an equation that we had
before, but only from a
different point of view.
See, now instead of asking for
the slope of this circle or
what have you, let's work
the question this way.
Let's suppose we have
a particle.
The particle is moving along the
curve 'x squared' plus 'y
squared' equals 25 where for
physical reasons we'll say 'x'
and 'y' are in feet, and that
we know at the point 3 comma
4, 'dx dt'--
the horizontal component of the
speed of the particle--
is 8 feet per second.
And the question is we'd
like to find 'dy dt',
the vertical component.
In other words, the particle
is moving along the circle.
We know that at the point 3
comma 4, 'x' is increasing at
the rate of 6 feet per second
while the increasing
x-direction is this way.
So somehow or other, we know
that the particle is moving
along the curve in
this direction.
You see, if it were moving
in this direction, it's
x-coordinate would be
decreasing, not increasing.
And the question that comes
up is how do we find
'dy dt' in this case?
Well, see, all we do in this
case is we say look-it,
instead of assuming that 'y' is
a differentiable function
of 'x', why don't we assume
that both 'x' and 'y' are
differentiable functions
of 't'?
In other words, let's assume
that 'x' and 'y' are
differentiable functions of 't'
that make this an identity
in terms of 't'.
Now again, as long as this is an
identity and we're assuming
that 'x' and 'y' are
differentiable functions of
't', there is absolutely
no reason why we can't
differentiate both sides of this
equation with respect to
't' instead of with
respect to 'x'.
If we do that, we get what?
'2x' 'dx dt' plus '2y'
'dy dt' equals 0.
You see the same principle as
before even though we're now
differentiating implicitly
evidently what we could call
parametric equations.
We're assuming that 'x' and
'y' are differentiable
functions of 't'.
You see, from this identity now,
we can conclude that 'dy
dt' is 'minus x/y'
times 'dx dt'.
And now, you see, to polish off
our particular problem,
namely, we're interested
in what?
When 'x' was 3, 'y' was
4, and 'dx dt' is 8.
In other words, I find out
from this that 'dy dt' is
minus 6 feet per second.
You see, the idea was that 'x'
and 'y' as positions of the
point were related by the fact
that 'x squared' plus 'y
squared' had to equal 25.
In other words, this is what
we physically call a
constraint.
And by the way, this is what
makes calculus such an
important, powerful,
analytical tool.
Notice that in doing this
particular problem, I never
had to know explicitly
what functions 'x'
and 'y' were of 't'.
All I had to know was what?
That 'x' and 'y' were
differentiable
functions of 't'.
I don't care how the particle
was moving away from the point
3 comma 4 as long as 'x' and
'y' were differentiable
functions of 't', this is how
the rates 'dy dt' and 'dx dt'
had to be related.
Well, let me summarize what
was really important
conceptually about
today's lecture.
The most important thing
conceptually was what?
With all of our talk about
explicitly writing an output
and an input, in many important
mathematical
relationships, the variables
that we're concerned with are
implicitly related.
In other words, we are not told
what 'y' looks like in
terms of 'x', but rather how 'x'
and 'y' are interrelated,
and from here we have to
find a derivative.
And the way we do this is that
we make the assumption that an
appropriate identity exists,
that 'y' is an appropriate
function of 'x' that makes the
relationship an identity.
The validity of when you can
do this, for example,
geometrically, when do you wind
up not having a point
that includes a vertical
tangent, a point where you
can't separate the curve
doubling back?
That turns out to be a rather
difficult point from an
analytical point of view, a
point that we will return to
in a more advanced context when
we deal with functions of
several variables.
But for the time being, all I
want you to be left with in
this lecture is the feeling that
we can, given an implicit
relationship under the proper
conditions, assume that the
appropriate explicit
relationship exists and that
we can differentiate both
sides as an identity.
Well, enough said for today, and
until next time, goodbye.
NARRATOR: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.